the first of its kind case a judge is
punishing Johnson & Johnson for what the
court says is its role in the opioid
crisis the judge ordered the healthcare
giant to pay five hundred and seventy
two million dollars to the state of
Oklahoma he ruled the company downplayed
the risks of opioids which the state
blames for more than four thousand
deaths the judge's decision says Johnson
and Johnson used the phrase pseudo
addiction to convince doctors at
patients who showed signs of addiction
were actually being under treated for
pain the suggested remedy for this under
treatment was to prescribe still more
opioids Johnson & Johnson plans to
appeal the ruling it says in a statement
quote the states claims violate
fundamental principles of due process by
seeking to hold a company liable for
conduct permitted under federal law and
regulations we have with us now Mike
hunter Oklahoma Attorney General he led
the state's lawsuit Mike good morning
good morning how are you all when I
visited you in your office maybe a year
ago when you talked about this case you
said you were looking forward to trial
you had confidence in your laws who had
confidence in your state I guess that
confidence paid off at the same time you
were asking for 17 billion and you only
got five hundred and seventy seventy two
million so how satisfied to you this
morning well anytime you win a case and
the verdict is in excess of half a
billion dollars I think that's a W Tony
so we were we were lucky we were looking
to deal with the state's crisis with the
consequences of the oversupply the MIS
marketing the fraudulent practices of
Johnson & Johnson in a comprehensive way
over multiple years but this is a
significant judgment when you put it
together with the settlements of two
other defendants we've got almost a
billion dollars to deal with our
problems here in Oklahoma can you
explain to us Mike exactly what Johnson
& Johnson did and at one point you said
they had created a public nuisance by
fueling the crisis can you lay that out
specifically what they do well this
shameful stream of Commerce began back
in the mid nineties when Johnson &
Johnson conspired with other industry
partners to begin creating this
situation with regard
- we've got to treat pain and so if you
don't treat pain you're not being
responsible to your patients so they
needed a magic drug and the magic drug
was opium so they bought a poppy farm
down in Australia they're subsidiaries
wholly owned subsidiaries ran the poppy
farm and for the last two decades
they've been supplying 60% of the active
pharmaceutical ingredient for farm for
prescription opioids in this country so
when we call them the kingpin of the
crisis in Oklahoma in this country we
mean what we say subsequent to that they
miss market they miss marketed the
products they've Rajal n't ly
misrepresented the addictive qualities
that conspired with their industry
partners to head off changes that would
have abated the epidemic certainly would
have improved the ability of
policymakers to deal with it so Johnson
& Johnson is in this up to their neck
and now Alex Gorsky write a check Mike
you're saying yes absolutely absolutely
ok Johnson Johnson says they are not
going down without a fight they plan to
appeal they said that the decision is
flawed and they said that you quote
failed to present evidence that the
company's products or actions created
that public nuisance why do you think
they are taking that position and is the
evidence that and where is the evidence
what's the evidence you see that Johnson
and Johnson broke the law well they must
have been at a different trial for the
seven weeks that we were here in Norman
or they they've had an attack of amnesia
the judge's order clearly establishes
their culpability with regard to what's
happened in this state and so they could
ignore that they can deal in double-talk
and some kind of Orwellian spin about
what's happened in Oklahoma with regard
to this decision but the judge clearly
found that they were responsible and
they've been assessed over half a
billion dollars and we expect them to
pay again we expect the CEO of this
company to step up quit being a
hypocrite write the checks so we can
start dealing with the mess that they've
created here in Oklahoma mr. Attorney
General
people are now going to be looking north
of
to Ohio where there is a massive
consolidated case involving lots of
opioid manufacturers and distributors
what does the ruling in your case mean
for that bigger picture case and for the
larger crisis of opioid addiction in
this country well I hope it's helpful to
my fellow attorneys general around the
country there's a seven-week record now
that establishes the conduct not only of
Johnson & Johnson but other opioid
manufacturers what they conspired to do
what they ignored what they
misrepresented so I hope it's a template
for the rest of the country I hope it's
a template for those who are trying to
seek redress for their clients cities
and counties and states that's something
that we feel very proud about we we
tried this case we did what we needed to
do we made a record and I can't say
enough about the courage that Judge
showed in this case by looking at the
facts and finding this company
responsible for what they've done to
Oklahoma certainly a big win for you mr.
hunter thank you so many lives lost
thank you so much